This is a shot
from Pixar's latest movie, "Soul."
Even though it's
animated, everything about
how the fingers float
from one key to another
to the small details like
tendons moving in the hand
feels just as real as
the reference footage that inspired it.
While Pixar has used reference
footage since the beginning,
it could not have pulled off a scene
with movement this nuanced and realistic
back in 1995 for "Toy Story."
And it took years of
technological breakthroughs.
So how did Pixar get here?
First off, they have an army
of animators and riggers.
We talked to seven who worked on "Soul"
to see how far Pixar has come.
Let's start over 26 years ago
with the technology built for "Toy Story."
Getting a given character to move
starts in Pixar's rigging
and modeling department.
Whenever you're thinking
of a character model
before it's rigged, it's in
a completely neutral pose.
There's no expression on the face.
The arms and legs are all straight.
And so the controls that
we put in in rigging
lets parts of the body
move like you would pose
like a doll or a puppet.
To get a clearer idea of the basics,
let's start with this
character model of Woody.
The rigging department will add the rig,
which is essentially an inner skeleton.
Throughout this rig you
can see all these controls
called animated variables, or avars,
which animators use to make
different parts of a
character move around.
This early version of Woody
had 596 of those controls,
which may seem like a lot,
but by 2019's "Toy Story 4,"
Woody had more than 7,000.
To make things a little more complicated,
one control point is often connected
to other control points.
So moving one in the eyebrow
will move the wrinkles on the forehead.
Adding more controls to
these "Toy Story" characters
would have let them move with more nuance,
but back then, Pixar was
making a brand new rig
for every single character.
That would change with "Toy Story 2."
Pixar introduced Geppetto,
later updated to Presto,
which allowed animators to reuse
and adapt rigs for multiple characters.
This sped up the animation process
and gave animators more control
over movements and facial expressions.
The new software provided
a template of two-legged
and four-legged rigs that could be altered
depending on the specific
needs of a character.
According to rigger
Jared Fong, the sea lions
in "Finding Dory" were actually
constructed from dog rigs,
with legs folded into flippers.
More control with Geppetto also meant
more expressive facial movements,
as seen in 2003's "Finding Nemo."
To really nail the character's emotions,
animators used reference footage.
Now fish don't have eyebrows or eyelids,
but eyebrows are so important
for expressing human emotions.
So animators decided to
add eyebrow-like lumps
to characters like Marlin and Dory.
And replicating real facial expressions
meant connecting more control
points with each other.
You can see that with
Dory. The control points
around her mouth are connected
with her eyes and her cheeks,
giving her a more believable smile.
A smize, if you will.
After making major strides
with toys and sea creatures,
the most daunting challenge
was yet to come: humans.
Mr. Incredible consisted
of 426 primary controls,
111 secondary animation controls
for more subtle movements,
and 1,061 modeling controls
for sizing and other adjustments.
Thanks to Geppetto, the
rigging and modeling team
could perfect Mr. Incredible
and then reuse his rig
for other characters.
And to really make his movements realistic
they used full-body reference footage.
For example, this clip where an animator
lifts up this exercise ball
was helpful for moments like this,
where Mr. Incredible
lifts up an Omnidroid.
And the team didn't animate
just a rigid skeleton.
On top of the skeleton
was a layer of muscles,
which could bulge and flex.
And the skin on top of that
would need to respond realistically.
So Pixar developed a
new system called Goo.
This allowed the animators to see the skin
and muscles react in
real time as they worked,
allowing for greater
flexibility and movement
and more control over how humans move.
Goo led to breakthroughs in moving
more challenging body
parts, like the shoulders,
which were more primitive
in earlier films.
The Buzz Lightyear
shoulder's a ball and socket.
Woody's shoulder is just a stitch line.
He's got no shoulders, right?
That arm just hinges.
Mr. Incredible has a
big old strong shoulder.
How you get a trapezius
muscle there in the shoulder,
and how it moves in the
pectoral, really complex stuff.
The rigs built for "The Incredibles"
were designed to let the characters
stretch further than the average human.
Which was important for Elastigirl,
who needed to transform
into all shapes and sizes.
And just like how superheroes
needed to react to forces like gravity,
so too did the cars in
Pixar's next feature, "Cars."
Pixar extended its technological
boundaries yet again
with a system called ground locking,
which made sure the cars
always stayed on the same path,
regardless of terrain,
without animators having to
move them frame by frame.
We had to have our characters
be able to follow the
contours of the ground
without having to animate them,
like up and down if it
was like, a rolling hill.
So it's going to move along these things.
And then we're going to
animate on top of that.
Because of ground locking,
Lightning McQueen could now
drive smoothly on a flat road
that turns into a very
windy path automatically.
This may seem like a specific advancement
just for the "Cars" movies,
but it would be important
for some of the most memorable
characters in "Soul."
By 2007, animators could have
up to 150 controls in the human face.
So they could give characters
a much wider range of emotion.
Perfect for a movie like "Ratatouille,"
which is largely set in the human world.
All these intricate controls allowed for
the complex array of expressions
seen on Chef Skinner.
Look at how far Chef
Skinner's mouth extends
as he's yelling at Linguini.
According to supervising
animator Mark Walsh,
the tech wouldn't have been
able to handle such a stretch
in "Toy Story" or "Finding Nemo."
The groundbreaking muscle
work in "The Incredibles"
allowed animators to give Linguini
more spontaneous movements in the scenes
where he's controlled
by Remy in the kitchen.
By the time "Toy Story
3" came out in 2010,
Pixar's animators had
gotten such precise control
over how characters move,
that it's surprising
they'd want to take a step backward.
But they actually relied on fewer controls
to better replicate the
trademark toy movements
audiences knew and loved.
If a character has a
limited range of motion
in its shoulder, what
we'll do is we'll basically
lock off some of that range of motion,
and then that forces you to
animate it in a different way.
They still had room to pick and choose
what they would keep
about the old characters
and where to elevate them.
For example, they could
have put 25 controls
in each of Buzz's eyebrows, but
decided to keep them simple,
like when he had just three
per brow in the original,
while also giving Spanish Buzz
these complicated flamenco-like moves.
There was one particularly
hard toy to animate:
the octopus named Stretch.
Despite the innovations in stretchiness
from "The Incredibles,"
making eight tentacles
stretch and curl was
still a daunting task.
We're fighting against the computer.
The computer wants to make things
that are that are solid
and that are perfect.
But it was a challenge they would
eventually master in "Finding Dory."
The hardest part of an octopus
to replicate is the tentacles,
which need to bend, curl, and unfurl.
You can see early attempts
at this with Stretch
and this octopus-like monster
all the way back in "Monsters, Inc."
In "Finding Dory," Hank also needed
to move around quite a
bit and grab onto things,
like this coffeepot.
Hank also had more than
350 suckers combined
on his tentacles.
Those were so unpredictable
that they had to be simulated,
a process where movements
are automated using code,
like with strands of hair and clothing.
The tentacles themselves were
so dynamic that when one moved
it would move other parts
of Hank's body as well.
And animators used an altered
version of this tentacle rig
on Dante in "Coco," giving
the dog a long, twisty tongue.
You can see it grab onto objects
here in the short film "Dante's Lunch."
But the biggest challenge
for "Coco" was music.
Pixar had to figure out how to get Miguel
to accurately play guitar.
So they strapped GoPros
directly to guitars,
giving themselves the
closest possible angle.
They would listen to the guitar music
and mimic the exact finger
and string movements.
It looks so authentic.
But Pixar found it could
push this even further
and make playing music
look even more real in 2020's "Soul."
As with previous Pixar films,
some assets were reused from "Coco."
For example, the same rig
built for the "Coco" guitars
was repurposed for Miho's bass.
We modified it for four strings
and just kind of repositioned
it to work for that.
For the scenes where Joe plays piano,
they went far beyond
just matching the music
directly to audio.
For reference footage,
Pixar captured Jon Batiste
playing piano at multiple angles.
Then, character technical
director Jason Davies
and the rigging team built a piano rig,
which functions like a digital piano.
Davies fed the audio files
directly into the rig,
and the piano would play automatically
in time with the music.
If a key lit up blue,
the animators would place
Joe's left hand there, and his right hand
would be placed on any
key that turned red.
They also tried developing a simulation
for Joe's piano playing,
but it proved tricky,
as his finger was too heavy
on the small piano keys.
So Davies developed a finger contact rig
similar to one used on "Coco."
Just like in "Coco," where fingers
moved the strings on guitars,
Dorothea's fingers could
play the saxophone,
and most importantly,
Joe could play the piano.
When their fingers would
intersect the space
where a key was, so it pushes
down into the keyboard,
it would calculate the proper angle
that that piano key needed to rotate
to make it look like he's pushing it.
While the piano played on its own,
the hand still needed to capture
the complicated motions of playing.
Which is why Joe was
equipped with 292 controls
in each of his hands.
That's about half the amount of controls
in Woody's entire body
in the first "Toy Story."
The riggers added variables to Joe's hand
that they had never used before.
According to character
model lead Mara MacMahon,
the team even added a control
for each tendon in Joe's hands.
So that was something that could kind of
capture the tension in his
hands as he's playing the piano.
So there's a control for each hand,
just to make a tendon
appear if the animator
wanted to really, like,
emphasize that particular pose.
These state-of-the-art
hand and wrist controls
weren't just useful for playing music.
They also allowed for flexibility.
Like Linguini in "Ratatouille,"
Joe is tall and lanky and has
a lot of frenzied movements
that had to be highlighted in scenes
where he is inhabited by 22.
For all of this, Joe had
477 controls in his face
and 789 additional controls
throughout his entire body,
giving him 1,266 controls total.
Conversely, they limited
the movements on Dorothea
to show her regal stature.
They even went as far as
removing subtle blinks and nods.
It's all in like, the look, you know.
How they hold their head
up, or how they just
set their gaze upon
whatever they're looking at.
But sometimes it's the
simplest-looking actions
or characters that prove
the hardest to control.
Take the counselors.
They look like simple 2D lines,
but they were the most
complicated characters to animate.
Doing the counselor characters for "Soul"
was pushing our limits
of what we could do.
And they turned out amazing.
That's building on 25, 26 years of history
to get to that point.
Terry consisted of around 300 controls.
A new tension control allowed animators
to sharpen or add an angle by
assigning it a higher value.
This allowed Terry and the Jerrys
to randomly grow fingers off their hands.
Plus, they were able to
easily transition between
Terry's multiple forms
using just a few controls,
pivotal in scenes where Terry
mutates into objects on Earth,
like this handrail, or this bag of chips.
But of course, even
something so new and unusual
couldn't have been made without
looking to Pixar's past.
The stretchy software that
built Hank and Dante's tongue
allowed Terry to disguise
herself in elaborate ways,
like in this heart monitor,
and this brick wall.
And the counselors couldn't just
move the way a person could,
posing another major challenge.
Since they don't have legs, right,
They just slide around on the ground.
The closest analogy is actually "Cars"
and that kind of stuff.
That meant they needed to borrow from
the same ground-locking
technology pioneered in "Cars"
to keep the counselors in motion.
When you get so good at making
things move realistically,
it's OK to sometimes let
your imagination run wild.
We're not trying to make things look
necessarily perfectly real.
What we're trying to do is
make sure that the emotions
that are coming out of the characters,
and what they're thinking, feel 100% real.